la reconstitution du meurtre du petit
grégory a eu lieu à lépanges sur vologne
elle devait permettre de vérifier
l'emploi du temps de la mère du petit
garçon qui est au centre du débat à
propos de sa culpabilité sur place notre
envoyé spécial marcel trillât coupable
ou innocente
ce soir encore prêt s'il wilm conserve
son secret on attendait beaucoup
pourtant de la reconstitution de ce
matin destinée à préciser les faits et
gestes de la mère de grégory le 16
octobre 1984
entre 17h et 17h30 en fait deux thèses
inconciliables se sont opposés à nouveau
sous le regard du juge lambert la
première se fonde sur le témoignage de
bernard colas il est l'un des derniers à
avoir vu christine villemin dans sa
voiture avant la disparition de l'enfant
vers 17 heures lorsqu'il est revenu de
sa promenade quotidienne au moment où
christine partait à la recherche de son
fils il était d'après le minutage
effectué ce matin
17h33 pour madame claude ont au
contraire il était environ 17 heures 20
elle remontait avec ses vaches devant la
maison des villes mme deux affirmations
fragile comme tous les témoignages
humains une contradiction pourtant
capital pour christine villemin dans le
premier cas elle ne dispose pas du temps
matériel nécessaire pour commettre le
crime qui lui est reproché
dans le second cas sa culpabilité le
lien possible
les vérifications d'aujourd'hui n'auront
pas suffi pour trancher